this standard process and viruses I
thank you Chris
I want to thank the organizers also for
giving me the opportunity of getting
this talk which is totally new to me so
I had to build it from scratch
and so we'll see how it goes on never
given the talk even remotely related to
this song so my first reaction was to go
over 76 submissions one by one and that
I figured out that okay so let's see how
it goes on and I'm please interrupt me
with lots of questions okay so a few
words about the nice post quantum crypto
standardisation process so if you are
interested to know about it here are the
links and that can be read within I
don't know when however and this one
much more hours
it sometimes entertaining so in short
mr. wants to standardize digital
signatures and came some that are secure
even even against quantum computing
there is a list of criteria and I've
selected a few which I find probably the
most relevant so the camera the key
exchange mechanism should be secured
against a CCA attack sound chosen
ciphertext attack so it should allow to
encrypt or exchange keys that are at
least 256 bits because the typical use
for this would be to combine it with a
symmetric key encryption are gone now
secure signatures should be secured
against chosen message attack both of
them for both of them there is a bound
on the number of queries that the
attacker can make so in OCC a model of
attacks the attacker can make decryption
queries and for the signatures
it can make signature queries so NIST
bounced on the number of queries to 2064
concrete bond on the number of queries
that the attacker is allowed to make and
then it gives us at a number of levels
of security so from one to five so I'm
just giving here an example I have no
preference together between a 1 2 3 4
and 5 I have no opinion whatsoever on to
which one is the most relevant but just
to give you an idea of what a level of
security means so level 5 means it's at
least as secure as key search for
aes-256 it's a moving target so if you
improve a key search for aes-256
second tomb leads and you are moving the
target which queries are our signature
queries and decryption craziest is a
classic honor some of the queries are
consumer so we get into this later this
one's a classic code because for example
if I sign now and I receive I'm the
signer and I receive a quantum query for
signatures on
I don't feel compelled on to reply yes I
know it's it's not it was half I own it
completely so indeed them in a if you
think of quantum computing to solve a
zero
so okay asymptotic we use go over but in
practice what does that mean now what is
the cost of running over for this type
of key exhaustive search I don't know
yeah that makes sense
maybe some things that it shows on is
that what so something that it hints at
is at high-performance computing based
on quantum computing it's totally
unclear attestation so what would you do
in practice to build a massive
computation so they are like
recommendations on how to do this so in
the nice document but using some things
that we call Mac the Mac steps on it's
only like hints at what to do and what
to look at he's super fridge if it's
nothing a super fridge and you're
probably not gonna so you just have to
know cool it down I mean your personal
[ __ ] like temporally stored the query
yourself that like you copy it and like
you can't copy a quarter states so kind
of mix it classica under the memories
alright so you cannot do it forever
no but if you people cook yourself and
you would you discard it
Wi-Fi doesn't transport qubits is the
normal use of it down
okay so some timeline so the cool
proposals was like three years ago
82 candidate was submitted 69 had the
minimal criteria check missed out of the
69 more encryption schemes or more cams
and signature skills far more then a
year ago it was the end of the first
round and 26 counted dates that have
gone round I don't see past to the
second one because some of accommodates
our male G's of round one candidates
still more came some than signatures so
one question is what next time so if you
read the so I have to thank not you know
for the end of this lie down so if you
read the NIST website
it's totally unclear so the commitment
was 2021
maybe there is around three or we select
algorithms was a message from the
mailing list last September by justin
Mooji saying that maybe there will be a
third round and we expect it to be in
June 2020 so in six months it's a very
interesting paragraph actually I've cut
it but it's it's an example of how not
to commit yourself commit yourself in
the most non committing way so
especially the end of it is but that was
confirmed in a more committing fashion
at quantum safe crypto workshop
organised by HC which is in European
so apparently they will be observed
robert schumann straight okay so let's
move to latest submissions so out of the
twenty six one two candidates twelve are
based on the tissues almost have found
nine games three signatures so was
released on geocells own user scheme
cells involved multi quadratic equations
could base it could base crypto Merkle
trees hash functions Jana rich posts
lots of beautiful things that I will not
cover during this talk now so if you're
interested go and read them maybe
something special about lettuces
compared to the others is that lettuces
are are the only ones that have both
camps and signatures so if you want to
rely on the minimal number of harnessed
assumptions take letitia's
post content is able to second hey I'm
speaking on your run the way also
there was no convey signature to the 69
and not to the 82
okay so 69 also is in total including a
three quadruple Osos congratulations leo
comment in this one so refuses
sociological conclusions out of this let
his base crypto enjoy the most focus out
of all of the others and the size of
maturity of the community are higher
love designing an encryption schema is
easier maybe than it was 10 years ago
and another conclusion from this is that
encryption schemes are seamen much
easier to design than signature skips on
from a surgical viewpoint or maybe a bit
we don't know how to do that for
encryption schemes but actually building
signatures concrete ones it's more
difficult um okay so why do we care
about all this
but when these are just Letitia so nine
latest games and those three signatures
you're more or less strict on what is a
Leticia
understanding would be
okay so why should we care so it's nice
to see interesting Siri coming to
practice the comments that I have in my
family very often is that I should make
myself useful because I am paid by the
states but maybe I should help the
economy somehow I guess I get bonus
points if that public funding helps
companies attaboy taxes and maybe more
seriously this raises some interesting
problems or put more emphasis on
existing open problems during the rest
of this talk I will overview the CEM
candidates overview the signature
candidates and then I will comment about
some problems that are somehow related
out to this standardization problema
forum cetera like I don't claim that
these are the interesting programs in
general it's just my personal choice I
mean your list of reasons doesn't think
that we should find secure first quantum
Krypton
okay so so maybe an observation on Kemps
is that all nine of them have a general
design which is extremely related so as
they all somehow follow from the
following general design slide slide and
you take this general framework and
instantiate it in different ways so we
will see our different options for
different steps into the framework and
if you do the combinatorics then you end
up with more than nine put and shoulder
proposals so you can come up with yours
okay so we have the ring which is a
isomorphic to a copy of Zed an integer Q
which is typically much larger than two
and our Q which is our quotient hit by Q
R so what is key Jenna the public is a
metric sum over that ring our Q the
secret key is a vector s over R and here
this is not capturing a Solio just
pointed out to me that this is not
capturing one schema would be a metrics
and this a and F R such that s is small
compared to Q and s times a is also
small compared to you so we'll see in
the next slide that there are several
ways to achieve this how do we encrypt
our so the public is a so to encrypt a
binary message Emma which is potentially
a vector and we build down T and E small
and we turn now a times T plus e plus
say Q over two times mo so this choice
okay so now how do i decrypter I just
multiply by s and Radha
because s s transpose times C that's a
CT to s times a smaller like design of
the public key so I get small times
small round still smaller
plus sound ste small time small it's
still smaller
plus R Q of R 2 times STM so if I
somehow all this is small compared to Q
so if I take the most significant bits
I end up with HT times mo it's not
telling you hot we cover Emma I only
recovers in a product with less but
we'll see that there are ways around
I'll give you two way to two ways to
interns instantiate instantiate this and
so the oldest one is a general one we've
mentioned several times so this week
that it doesn't have a Porsche but it
has actually worked all the last five
years and it's pretty efficient so the
ringer would be a polymer Rainier G of X
mod P for some large degree P which
preferably is reducible and we set H to
be G / FM where both F and G are small
polynomials so small in the sense that
they have small coefficients so this H
is za here a matrix with a single entry
and when I did Krypton so I do so f 1
would be the ELSA so f is small compared
to Q and F times a is equal to G it's
small compared to one way to build so
something interesting about it is that
when we recover when were with the
Krypton so I said that we recover the
inner product between know the secret
vector s and the secret vector Emma and
the message vector Emma here there are
no vectors just callosum so I will cover
F times Emma
scale also also put in a very Mia so I
recover F times M I Phi divided by F
Erica I'm all those are ways to do it
then there is a another strategy that we
often attribute to you by chefs keep a
cat an IDF so ok so it it's it works in
the elderly in the general degree set up
so we have the matrix a which would be a
uniform so here are Q could be a
polynomial ring or zq large matrix
polymer ring or matrices of the forum
earrings so this matrix is uniform and
then we sample SEO and SEO smaller and
we set a to be 0 concatenated with - SEO
SEO + video and we observe that when we
multiply by this vector S which is s 0
concatenated with 1 s transpose times a
consuls out and we essentially rococo so
noise so we ended a half an a such that
an Anessa
which is more such at seh is also small
compared to another way to do it and now
ok so now if I do this in the naive way
I recover s-sometimes of message vector
so I'm losing information but one way to
get around it is to impose it the last
coefficient of s sound is 1 and to
impose on Sat the plaintext vector is 0
concatenated with Emma which is a short
plaintext on so that when I do my inner
product as you always multiply by 0 and
M is x by 1 Nariko has a message
is only technical side from
okay so let's move on
so what about security okay so we have
when we encrypt we have a times T plus T
plus P over to Emma and we want a a T
plus e to look from the so that if we
have this the schema has a chance to be
CPA secure that is a secured and against
chosen plaintext attacks okay so in
particular we would a to be to loop from
done so depending on the choice of
general construction this would be
called the entry wound SSM channel
assumption on its own page one time or
another but we like assumption because a
was built with W Center so depending on
your design here for the security of the
public key we either relies on some kind
of entry like unless essential so on on
some lwe like honey so sumption and I
for the cipher text ax we have 80 plus e
which we would like to look
pseudo-random assuming sub pseudo on the
mess of a and again that's some kind of
a EE like assumption so how do we get
CCA security from CPA security so there
are generic transformations for this all
transformations in the random Oracle
Madonna
so these transforms they make use of a
hash function which is modeled as a
random marker so we can query the hash
function and we get values on in the
quantum attacker setting it makes sense
to model this hash functions as
contumely access Ebola random functions
so we can make quantum queries to this
Rhonda Michaels and that's called the
quantum random Oracle Madonna so maybe
two K Z sound at least at the moment as
far as we know if the scheme is
deterministic and perfectly correct Xena
we can use also so-called s XY
transformer which enjoys the tide pool
from the corn and there are not many
schemes are out of the nine
encryption schemes that I gave that are
perfectly correct as far as I know there
is one and true primer but I'm not sure
there are others and updating any spenny
dwell on it otherwise you can use a
violent of the Fujisaki you can go to
transformer and a good reference point
for this is a vapor they hope is other
months and a cookie okay so it handles
at least in this paper of the handle
decryption a wall see whether they
handle it Twila that's a bit subjective
Oh we'll get back to this but the
hundred
you think there was contesting the
correctness
there are several theorems from the
paper most are uncontested it's it's
it's maybe not true I don't know it's a
very beautiful paper which is written in
a in a very modular way and you can
combine different parts of the paper
into different in in different ways so
checking full correctness is formidable
it's a very nice rate though
okay so then which which algebraic set
up um so we can take matrices over CQ
that's one choice we can take the
polynomial ring as EQ of X might be for
some can take matrices of a polynomial
rhenium last 2 kgs you can say you can
take different polynomials P and there
have been several proposals and even
controversies on how to choose P you can
also choose different queues a common
choice would be P equal x to the n plus
1 with any power of 2 and Q congruent to
1 mod to n because that gives efficient
arithmetic in those rings those are
interesting choice of Q with your power
of 2 because of choices here depending
on the choice that you make you end up
with different action what is at stake
when you do this choice and so that
impacts the underlying harness
assumption so maybe LW / manganui or
would you let w/e i thought i know that
doesn't seem to impact actual security
in terms of attacks that doesn't do any
difference it has significant impact on
efficient
now you can choose a whole you get two
small vectors also in the schema s T and
E are smaller and then you again have
plenty of choices you can use integer
motions central binomial distributions
ternary distributions possibly sparse
ternary distributions you can use a
deterministic e obtained by rounding
yeah so you compute a times T and you
keep the most significant bits so plenty
of choices are you can probably think of
more options so what is at stake when
you do this so that impacts the
underlying harness assumption if paucity
is pushed a lotta that actually impacts
on security then you end up with other
attacks on like a greedy so for example
lines around five submission hogatha the
hybrid attack is something that measures
small s T and E so if you if you choose
them very small so why would you choose
them very small so it has two
interesting potential level application
so you can choose Q smaller if you
choose the small thing smaller and
smaller pew is still large compared to
the small things that allows you to
decrease Q so an extreme case is a
solution cube is below eight bits or you
can get perfect likeness
moyzisch
was done in the entry point and then how
to set parameters very briefly on this
one because that was covered already
so the comment strategy goes back to the
EDPs paper so first time you forget
about the CCA a grade reduction does so
okay we have a transformer in the QM
with a loss in the security profile no
one takes us that lost into account when
setting parameters you can someone take
this loss into a contract not not a
camera that would be true for signatures
it would it would result in horrendous
parameters on especially the time of
writing of photons were so bad that
all the other bosses maybe maybe I can
say that extra primer could take the
Ross into account but none would
disagree of resistors imagine that you
could write that intro prime can rely on
the XXY transform and the loss of s XY
is a question
doing a lot of advertisement for untrue
prime so far okay so express the
selected harness assumption as a ladies
problem so you translate your
lwe type of assumption or type of
assumption as a lattice problema and
then you try to assess how strong that
is reduction now needs to be to break
the schema so that translates by good
miss Chen PhD thesis into a block size
for UK Zetas and then you use the cost
of the best known SVP solvers and in
that dimension which Martin discussed
about okay so that give you how much it
costs to solve for specific instance but
it doesn't tell you how to set
parameters on so when you set parameters
typically it would try many possible
choices and keep the most efficient or
not according to your target function
for efficiency and most efficient one
which is at least below some security
above some security cost lots of
different parameters and among those
that are above some custom to break the
schema you keep those that give you you
can try to minimize sizer costs in my
simplicity whatever that means
questions on the Kim song
okay so the situation is very different
for signatures how much fewer of them
are but the designer is a much more
varied so if you were but more diversity
somehow so let me go into somewhat more
into details for this signature
algorithm so first let's start with
Falcone on so yeah you know idea is to
combine and true sign now with the GPD
framework ah so that it doesn't leak
information when you provide signature
so general intuition so the public key
is a quotient of two polynomials with
small coefficients then the secret key
is a small basis of some lettuce on the
edge of pairs of polynomials such that a
times H minus B is your Matt Q so you
already have one solution now thanks to
your wiki your public key generation and
you can build a second solution and
hopefully that gives you the full basis
and the signature would be a Gaussian
sample of the lattice cassette
yes and then on top of this and there
are lots of optimizations to actually
make it work efficiently in practice so
that results in very compact signatures
the downside is that the code or the
algorithms even somewhat complex on so
it requires this big ocean sampling
floating-point arithmetic of the way use
towards the subfields and to generate
yoki and also to generate the signatures
is beautiful I love it
so you can spend time looking at
interesting tourism and the harness
relies on solving an inhomogeneous
version of system so basically given a
charm the public key and some target
wire you want to find a small a such
that a times H is almost why
in distinguished 80 of the yeah so
that's okay before a good question thank
you for this question
it's much less Waring's and for
encryption schemes because F and G are
much less smaller so Ang's are very
close to sprout queue and if they were
both square root user would be actually
a proof of static statistical uniformity
but we are not too far from it that's a
kind of theoretical answer the practical
answer is that the key forgery attacks
when you look at figures are much less
are much more costly and the signature
forgery attacks on the parameters that
you choose it's much easier to much
easier custom to produce signatures
forgeries and to produce a keyholder
it is true this is the only assumption
needed in the proof right as long as you
it's like geo sir the probably is the
proper distribution of age so we are
using an age with FNG above the scribe
to bounce huh at some stage it would hit
regime whereas this would be the only
assumption but they are not valued on
the tree there isn't it true that this
is the only assumption but it's for the
specific distribution I guess you can
see this a homogeneous Reverend of his
where H is from some
citizen for encryption schemes
a special variant of rails really where
as the A's are chosen in some way
deletion and Tesla so they have a
similar design based on the works of
veggie member jiske 2012 paper so
basically it's translating our snores
discrete log type signatures into the
latest setting now once you've said this
it requires quite a lot of where to go
through so the public key is a is a
matrix of the moringa and the T is a
times s1 plus s2 the secret key is s1
and s2 and sign inga consists in proving
knowledge of s1 and s2 we're going to
explain more details how that works on
baby
just to comment on the result it
provides significant it's just rounding
and arithmetic math cube and it also
relies on the zoo harness of the same
same type of inhomogeneous virgin oxygen
same type of assumption so what type of
efficiency do we get so here I gave able
to compare so hopefully I'm comparing
comparable things so I took a
non-optimized
C code because Tesla didn't provide
optimized C code
is for a single signature because in
some cases you should produce many
signatures there are tricks to decrease
the cost say he's on beds from tanks in
cycles so what you can see in particular
is that the file corner signature 700
bytes that's much less and the deletion
or tapes last signatures ages we know by
spending a lot of effort on the
implementation side for example they
have a key gene which is horrendous
okay too many questions and lectures
it's partly based on the talk that was
given by Jacob and on the blog post live
when I wrote also some time ago so you
could be seen as some kind of date in
the energies or yet another version okay
so let me first go into the best known
algorithms type of questions so when we
set parameters we consider the best
known particle algorithms so it's
important to know what they are and how
they how their costs are extrapolating
so nothing discussed quite extensively
on this so let me insist a bit more so
for example I have sitting and
enumeration we push tasks as possible
it's also best known algorithms in
practice can they improve them even more
if they can be improved a lot times that
would have impact on situations
also the best known algorithms are all
your stapler so one natural thing to do
about them how to understand them and be
able to reason about them would be to
prove our disgust oh there are other
ways to understand the algorithm so
proofs is one possible way
experimentation is another way so if you
run lots of experiments on your
algorithms you somehow learn things
about they concrete computations and in
particular what can we do to support and
dispute this joystick so can be how far
can we go into testing same experimental
ee and here's the fact that de now to
call this type of algorithms makes it
easier to do experiments and also one
possible Avenue would be to improve our
cost lower bounds so improve our lower
bounds that means increase the lower
bound
somewhat easy to decrease a lower bomber
so in particular in many of these cost
estimates and we lower bombs the cost of
running because L by the cost of running
a single call to an SVP or less VP
enumeration or and SVP serum but there
are some things that we don't take into
account is that we do more than one
color so can we have a good intuition
and how many times we call this these
algorithms that would be an open problem
one more practical question even is
whether sitting out performs enumeration
for very large dimensions in particular
considering its memory requirements and
so it has on a Space Coast which didn't
kick in now so far we consider bigger
computations does it start to matter and
if it does how do we measure the cost of
that and now if we turn to quantum
computations how do we Costa massive
quantum computation question and as far
as I know the picture is not so clear
okay so another type of questions is a
choice of the assumptions that you make
to support the security of the schema so
somehow when you have a scheme you say
okay so if this problem is secure and
the scheme is secure but those are
questions related to this type of to
these assumptions so if you live in an
asymptotic world many of these
assumptions are put in real time
equivalents when you stretch the
parameters sufficiently but for concrete
parameters most of this vanishes off so
I have a provocative first question is a
double as okay as an assumption as LWR
so far all the proofs of LW hardness and
based on the LWR
assumption ah the old degrade do not
know why I did this works on top of Sun
that's also true all the proofs of LW
has been based on the LWR harness
assumption ah well these proofs are
better non satisfactory
do some rainy divergence thing to go
back to a wlw are is possibly stronger
than oh yeah
those thing points to the opposite so
far and it has been introduced much
before W so as an idea I record are that
dates back to a and there is a secret
give out the most significant bits of
the item size so it's one and a
one-dimensional LWR which is as hard as
it WR in dimensions do you agree that
one-dimensional deliveries equipment
well W one-dimensional nwe versus
n-dimensional W so we have what is to be
answer but I live in I live in an sn2
cheek so I pretend to live in an
asymptotic world where we lose a lot on
the factors
there is or how much absolute nice to
smell like how many bits are here so
here you can set it to be one over
police compared to the you can also set
the nice to be one over pretty and I'm
saying that there's a qualitative or
exponential difference if you go through
the reduction there's a exponential
difference in how much how big the noise
is the reduction goes both ways on you
need to put it on your leg but it
doesn't quantify harness on what
quantifies how much is a relative noise
so recognize this is almost preserved on
the right if now it is almost pretty of
time you only lose a point of effect on
rate of noise yes angry if it's a great
was the rate of noise or like hit a
number problem they're giving away like
a very tiny amount of the amount of
rounding is a very tiny amount to give
out very humid humid very few bit even
less the it's defined in a in a general
way so you could give whichever function
of the bits that you want but the easy
set is a range of parameters which is of
interest to them is to give out say one
bit that's the point giving out one bit
it's not consistent with your asymptotic
thing because once you give out only one
bit that's noise the flat one and if it
was it means relative noise which is
very small noise rate see no it's rate
time which is ready wait one bit of the
product that noise rate is enormous it's
like
obliterating everything
it's 1 equal to 2 GMO and you'll give
out the most me if you can be so easy
alpha yeah exactly
okay so if you pay a call on Romeo
factor in the switching between this
time oh yeah so if you take just one be
2 it will not go through so you you need
to take a bit more than one bit on login
login bit no get out of em very similar
and though this set of parameters best
known attacks are there's something
about the inner product that I think the
inner product compresses you down just
to seek you even if your group size is
skewed to the animal so you're you're
hiding like almost all the best let's
continue aflame but whatever works here
for another video to extends to in the
video
okay so that was a very provocative
state I'm sorry about this what about
MWe versus pwe so asymptotically
equivalent when you use matrices of
small ranks we're in the middle of
season everywhere in practice again so
that's interesting question on another
question is whether the entry assumption
is much more aggressive or not then the
p LW e and would you let the big e
assumptions pallazo type you can
interpret and true as a module for them
where there are unique shortest
solutions there are extremely small
solutions compared to what you expect in
a random so it's some kind of USDP for
rank two modules which is a bit special
and another problem which is used for
example in those three their submission
is a so-called integer M elderberry
problem with harmless still needs
investigating you therefore understand
this repair submission I assume that you
actually understand this submission to
the Sun sorry I'm not committing to
understanding fully any of the
submissions it's related to the Mersenne
submission or somehow which didn't make
you to want to some silly lines
okay so still related to assumption so
some schemes make more or less than that
assumption so even we stand out
assumption sometimes the parameters are
stretched down in a way which is quite
audacious o.g item that I prefer on this
slide and I think that's a very
important one because but I don't think
it has received a lot of attention this
question related to deletion and how
much it is no no this deletion relies on
some kind of harness of his his harness
assumption but it relies on sis for the
L infinity norm this parameter settings
it doesn't it does matter because if you
look at the norm of the solution so the
L infinity norm is much below Q but the
L 2 norm is above cube the L 2 norm is
usually bigger than here the L 2 norm of
the solutions is above cube so if you
analyze the schema instead in terms of
the L 2 norms of the solution so you
have a difficulty because the trivial on
vectors Q 0 0 0 0 are shorter and then
the norm bound that the L 2 norm bondas
that you happen they are still not
useful we are a range of parameters
where Q is really smaller compared to
the both the norms of the solutions so
one way to maybe go into this direction
would be to see if the mission show back
up papers that we discussed earlier this
week er expands on to this range of
parameter so very large l 2-norm
above q but still L infinity norm below
q and whether I'll go
we can exploit it or not and print it so
when you do these slopes of GSA's and so
on it messes up things completely
because it's queue vectors are already
below your L to do target nom that you
want to reach so so far the things that
we proposed in the deletion paper as an
algorithm to solve this problem is to
randomize the basis so that we forget
about this useless queue vectors and
then we run that this production very
short vectors but you run the maze
everything so that you hide them and
then you hope that when you run lettuce
production on it and you don't find them
again you'll find actually useful
vectors so I think this question is
interesting both from the harness
perspective and from the algorithm
perspective another way that parameters
have been stretched quite a bit is the
various shapes of noisy so so can this
be exploited into lettuce algorithm so
let's increase the concrete resistance
concrete harness of n true schemes
against the creation of Luca 2017
attacker
so 2017 ax is the one that tries to find
very short vectors in a lattice where
you have lots of unexpected initial
vectors overstretching true
so some submission say that doesn't
apply but it has not been substantiated
done with the KF 17 paper you can go
back or purely on time and move to the K
15 paper which would also apply possibly
to some scheme son Tina looks at a
binary lwe lwe was a secret is made of
binary and Teresa Jen's are better
algorithms at Avenue no particular this
algorithm are so all do when s is
uniform or s is sufficiently large all
algorithms are like to to Zn o in terms
of parameters for binary secrets it's 2
to the n over log log n o and that could
possibly apply to some of the schemes
where the noise has been chosen very
very smooth what a secret sometimes I've
been very very you know you've not like
my aha you didn't read the very end of
the case okay so what they suggested the
variant is that if you don't have enough
samples you just create them yourself
huh they rerun the amazing the samples
that you already have oh why don't you
like
in theory but in practice you can take
three or four tennis a paper would be
your stick in many ways on there's still
so much with a neighbor
I'm happy to be disproved on the round
the question is do you disbelieve the
heuristic so strongly that you're
willing to bet a crippling scheme on it
right so maybe for actual concrete time
it just maybe she's too costly that
could totally be the case but I think it
should be tried on it should be it
should be actually computed on the
choice of the polynomial ring so many
polynomials are proceedure now does this
impact security so for example can
cyclotomic polynomials be shown not bad
in in long the cyclotomic saw some words
and others can the other polynomials
selected by some of the niche candidates
be showed bad in some kind of way this
is open in many cases this translates in
terms of ideal SVP attacks but what do
these attacks on ideology actually say
because these attacks is known to extend
to lwe or module @wg
it's attacking a problem which has been
shown no easier and pl EE and Ahmet EE
but maybe the taxon is showing that
ideology P is not the right of sunshine
to start with and why and how do they
help choosing the parameter it's an
interesting area okay so what is the
impact of decryption arrows so most of
the candidates have decryption having
perfect perfect correctness so what is
the impact of this so in particular we
one possible question is to determine
the precise interplay between the
polynomial ring structure and the
probability of incorrect decryption so
as far as I know it's still not fully
understood
and assess the probability of having
weaker secret keys and if we want to
avoid this type of attacks via security
proofs
what what what does it impact what is
the impact on actual parameters on these
are like very concrete questions some
very very papers that I really enjoyed
recent papers that I really enjoyed is
the one big go you and so on and younger
from Isaac with few months ago which is
to start thinking about this type of
questions I find so another set of open
problems he is related to the kyo-ahn
proof so
so the Fujisaki Okamoto upgrade to CCA
security incurs the large loss in terms
of advantage to distinguish text so we
could ask to decrease the dependency of
the CC of the CP a distinguishing
advantage as a function of the
decryption error probability HK HK paper
there is a dependency in the security
laws which which is actually not small
at all for parameters that have been
chosen and partition the dependency is
also in terms of the number of
decryption tourism and in terms of the
distinguishing advantage of the CCF up
greater another possibility which would
be to show that some of these
dependencies are actually intrinsic we
have to pay for them there is a work at
TCC so a couple of months ago that
decrease the load the dependency on the
number of decryption Croatia and I have
a recent work with colleagues from the
University of Manoj is that decreases
the dependency in terms of the
so this is for encryption schemes and
there is a similar questions for
signature schemes some so for Falco now
the question doesn't really apply
because there is already a tight chompoo
from Tesla the set parameters so that
they actually take the security laws
into account but for deletion
it remains somewhat open and let me
mention three recent works on this arm
so in one work they killed two by 50 and
Schaffner they introduced a new
assumption so that we have a nice go
home proof under this new assumption but
it's somewhat artificial then there is a
paper from a crypto last year that has
somewhat good profound but under an
assumption which is not fully proven and
there is a paper value and century which
has a current proof with the degradation
in terms of the number of signature
queries which is very bad there is room
for for improvement
okay so this is it for the corset okay
and also I try to conclude our other
aspects are many other aspects are
related to dismissed standardization
process that I didn't cover so long that
accommodates efficient implementations
implementations implementations that you
have is actually doing what you want
resistance to side channel attacks and
how to measure and cause simplicity and
this is just register to the mailing
list and maybe I'll finish with the post
nice post quantum quick dose slider so
let's let's first comment on on the
basic isometric primitive like
encryption and signatures are so have
you reached the ceiling for basic
primitives on so in terms of efficiency
can we push the encryption even more in
terms of pushing leechers even more by
hand waving and which says are fewer
signature schemes with much more varied
type of design so there should be more
room for improvement for signatures
so in the we have a emerged improvement
for calico now in this draft which is
available on the trim so that's one type
of questions so another type of
questions would be with so all these
schemes as they rely on to run the
market Medela so one way to just forget
but queue horn on tightness and so on is
to you stand up with that folk song
without around the mic around so it
seems to give the less efficient scheme
so but how less efficient how much are
we going to pay to get standard method
scheme so if we want to and once we are
done with encryption and cynic chairs
what what next we want to implement in a
very efficient way is ID based
encryption of sufficient deployment
interest so that we put a lot of energy
on it zero net force and which would
have issues to voting and anonymous
credentials or computing on personal
data or and so good particular
applications is also
[Applause]